هي المره الاولى التي يغلق فيها الصرف
شوارع احدى البلدات الرئيسيه في كوسوفو
منذ تاجيج وتاجر الازمه حيث اقام
المتظاهرون الصلب حواجز اقام حواجز مصنوعه
من شاحنات محمله في بلده المترو بيتزا
الشماليه البلاد كما وضعوا الحواجز على
الطرق المؤديه الى الحدود مع صربيا ف رغم
ان استقلال كوزوفو عن صربيا عمره 14 عاما
الا ان الازمه مستمره فالعاصمه بروشتينا
طبعا تواجهم معضله حقيقيه في اقناع حوالي
خمسين الف صربي باقي شمال البلاد باحترامي
ومؤسساتها هؤلاء يستخدمون حتى هذه اللحظه
اللوحات المعدنيه وايضا وثائق التربيه
رافضين الاعتراف بالمؤسسات التابعه لكزوفه
ورغم خطه الحكومه التي شملت اعطاء السرب
على اراضيها فتره انتقاليه للتالم الا
انها قبلت بالاحتجاجات بعد انتهاء المهله
قوات حفظ السلام بقياده حلف الناتو في
كسوف الوضع الحالي في الشمال بالصعب
للغايه القوات اكدت مراقبه الموقف عن كسب
مبديه استعدادها للتدخل اذا ما تعرض
لاستقرار للخطر اما تركيا ايضا دخلت على
خط الازمه معلمان التن استعدادها للوساطه
وايضا تخفيف التوتر بين البلدين تركيا
اجرت بالفعل الاتصالات منفصله مع وزيري
الخارجيه في صربيا وايضا كذب وداعيه
للتحلي بضبط النفس هذا وتلعب العلاقات
الوديه بين بلغراد وموسكو دور في المخاوف
الغربيه من اندلاع ازمه في المنطقه خصوصا
ان صربيا معروفه بمواقفها الايجابيه تجاه
روسيا كيف لا وهي التي قاومت وما تزال
تقاوم الضغط للانضمام الى العقوبات
الغربيه ضد موسكو
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه
لنا هذا مستمر منذ 20 عاما لذلك نحن نعيش
حياه طبيعيه في قدر ما نستطيع وليس لدينا
اي توقعات للقادم على الاطلاق
[موسيقى]
انه لن تكون هناك حرب يعيش شعبنا الصربي
في كسابه حياه صعبه الامر ليس سهلا عليهم
لكن لن نصل الى مرحله الحرب اعتقد ان
رئيسنا الصربي لن يدعى هذا يحدث ولا يوجد
احد يريد صوت
[موسيقى]